نود ان ننقل للشعب السوداني
بتقييم
موضوعي وحقيقي انه بالامس لاول مره
كانت هنالك اراده سياسيه متطابقه من كل
الاطراف التي وقعت للاتفاق الاطاري اربع
نقاط حاسمه ابرزها الوصول الى توافق حول
مبادئ واسس الاصلاح الامني والعسكري كانت
مصدرا للتفاؤل الكبير الذي ابدته قوى
الحريه والتغيير عقب اخر اجتماع لاطراف
العمليه السياسيه من العسكريين والمدنيين
الموقعين على الاتفاق الايطالي
التفاؤل واتبعته الحريه والتغيير بتخوف
صريح مما تقول انه تيار قوي من انصار نظام
الرئيس المخلوع البشير يعمل بلا كلل
لافشال العمليه السياسيه عن طريق دق طبول
الحرب بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
المشاكل الثانيه المواجههنا برضو تغذيه
الصراع بين الاجهزه العسكريه في السودان
وبرضه وحنذكر اسم عديل مجموعه علي كارتي
تحديدا مجموعه على كارتيسين تغذي الصراع
بين الاجهزه العسكريه وتشغل في الناس
لانها هي تحاول تستعد لمحاوله خلق الفوضى
داخل الدوله السودانيه
رغم المشاحنات بين العسكريين وخلافات
المدنيين فان مسار الاتفاق الايطالي ما
زال مستمرا بورشه المقرره خمس ورش هذه هي
الرابعه ورشه العداله والعداله الانتقاليه
بعد انعقاد الورش الولائيه للعداله انطلقت
هنا في قاعه الصداقه بالخرطوم اولى جلسات
الورشه القوميه يطالب المشاركون فيها
بترسيخ دوله القانون وجبر الضرر لانتهاكات
كانت حاضره على مر الحقب ينقل البلاد من
حاله الحرب الى حاله السلام ومن حاله
التكاثوريه الى حاله الديمقراطيه
ده بالنسبه لنا هو الهدف الرئيسي ونرجوه
من المؤتمر ونتمنى ان تقلل هذه الاهداف
بالنجاح
مع قرب اكتمال النقاش حول قضيه العداله
والعداله الانتقاليه تتجه الانظار نحو
قضيه الاصلاح الام ني والعسكري واقناع بعض
الممانعين للاتفاق الايطالي بالمشاركه في
الاتفاق النهائي تمهيدا لتشكيل حكومه
مدنيه خلال شهر رمضان سالم الهاشمي
العربيه الخرطوم